Puede que no nos demos cuenta, pero el mundo,
nuestro mundo, está cambiando a toda marcha:
biotecnología, nanotecnología, robótica…
cada día en algún remoto lugar del planeta
se produce algún descubrimiento o alguna
patente que harán que nuestra vida sea más
fácil, más larga y mucho mejor.
Prácticamente, amigos de VisualPolitik, podemos
decir que estamos subidos en un Tren de Alta
Velocidad cuyo destino es el futuro.
De hecho, ya hay empresas increíbles, empresas
por cuya actividad parecen más propias de
un mundo de ciencia ficción ¿Queréis ver
algunos ejemplos?
Pues fijaros:
¿Conocéis Organovo?
Pues es una increíble empresa que cotiza
en el Nasdaq y qué se dedica, ni más ni
menos, que a la bioimpresión de tejidos para
implantar en el cuerpo humano y evitar así
la necesidad de hacer transplantes ¿Os imagináis
imprimir un hígado?
¿Y qué me decís de Modern Meadow?
Es una Start Up que quiere producir cuero
natural y carne sin matar un solo animal.
Vamos, que quieren producir sus propios filetes
en el laboratorio y llevarlos a los supermercados.
La pregunta es...
¿Te lo comerías?
Bueno, y otro caso, ¿Habéis oído hablar
de Illumina?
Pues es la compañía más grande dedica a
la secuencia del ADN.
Entre sus objetivos, detectar el cáncer antes
si quiera de que aparezcan los primeros síntomas.
Increíble ¿Verdad?
Pues esto son sólo tres ejemplos de cientos
y cientos de compañías que están literalmente
construyendo el futuro.
Pero….
¿Sabéis qué?
Esto no es lo mejor de todo: sin duda alguna
lo mejor es que el fin de la pobreza está
cada vez más cerca, está ya sobre la mesa,
a la vuelta de la esquina.
De todo esto os hablé ya en este otro vídeo,
si no lo habéis visto luego os dejo el enlace.
Pero, ojo, no solo hablamos de erradicar la
pobreza extrema, para nada.
Hablamos de que en pocos años las penurias
y las calamidades que supone, por ejemplo,
pasar hambre o no poder comer carne, o no
tener asistencia sanitaria o incluso no poder
irse de vacaciones van a ser una cosa rara,
una cosa poco frecuente.
Puede que penséis en este momento: bueno,
a Alberto se le ha ido la olla, está loco,
tiene que estar exagerando.
Pues, no, no me he vuelto tarumba, es más,
aquí, delante de vosotros estoy dispuesto
a apostar que en los próximos años vamos
a conocer la mayor época de prosperidad de
la historia del ser humano.
Y no soy el único que lo piensa, fijaros
en lo que dice el genio de la inversión,
Warren Buffet:
“Vuelvo a repetir lo que ya he dicho otras
veces y seguiré diciendo en el futuro.
Nuestros hijos y nietos son la generación
más afortunada de la historia”.
O también en lo que dice Barack Obama:
“La verdad es que si tuviéramos que elegir
cualquier momento del transcurso de la historia
humana para vivir, elegiríamos este, ahora
mismo”.
Pues bien, amigos, aun voy a deciros más:
esta avalancha de prosperidad implica oportunidades
como nunca hemos imaginado.
Pero para los que no me creáis, vayamos como
siempre a los datos.
LA EXPANSIÓN SIN PRECEDENTES DE LA CLASE
MEDIA
Se calcula que, a finales de 2016, atentos
a la cifra, 3.200 millones de personas pertenecían
YA a la clase media y cada año 140 millones
más ingresan en este selecto club.
Esto es como si cada año un país como México
dejase atrás la pobreza.
Y, ojo, porque este proceso se está acelerando
hasta tal punto que, en dos o tres años,
alrededor de 2020, por primera vez en la historia
del ser humano, la mayor parte de la población
pertenecerá a la clase media, lo que sumado
a la población rica dejará a la pobreza
en minoría y en franco retroceso.
Pero…
Antes de continuar, seguro que os estáis
preguntando, pero ¿Qué se considera como
clase media?
Como el nivel de renta depende de cada país,
cuando hablamos de clase media hablamos de
personas que pueden permitirse económicamente
comer una dieta variada, personas que pueden
hacer frente a imprevistos, personas que pueden
acceder a un vehículo o que por ejemplo pueden
estudiar.
Personas, en definitiva, que puede que no
sean ricos, pero desde luego ya no son pobres.
Y eso es algo nuevo en la historia de la humanidad.
¿Queréis ver cómo está cambiando el mundo?
Fijaros en Shanghái:
Mirad, para que os hagáis una idea de cómo
están cambiando las cosas, VAMOS A HACER
UNA PERSPECTIVA HISTORICA.
Cuando Napoleón guerreaba por Europa en todo
el mundo poco más de 2 millones de personas
podían considerarse de clase media.
Esto sería equivalente a menos de la mitad
de los habitantes que hoy tiene Singapur…
¿Increíble , verdad?
Pues bien, desde entonces tuvieron que pasar
150 años para que la clase media alcanzase
los 1000 millones de personas en la década
de los 70.
Hoy ya son más de 3000 y en 2021 se espera
que lleguemos a los 4000 millones.
El proceso cada vez es más rápido.
Y ojo, porque esta nueva clase media viene
pisando fuerte ¿No me creéis?:
“Según la encuesta mundial de valores de
2015 las personas que forman la clase media
en los países emergentes sienten que su éxito
es consecuencia de su trabajo duro, del ahorro
y de su perseverancia.
En consecuencia, no apoyan las subidas de
impuestos para pagar planes sociales”
Como ya vimos, también aquí en VisualPolitik,
la población de muchos de los países emergentes
son entusiastas del capitalismo: quieren prosperar
trabajando, hacienda negocios, comerciando.
Sí, la ciudad que estáis viendo es Hanoi,
la capital de Vietnam, el país donde más
gusta el capitalismo de todo el mundo.
Me parece, amigos, que en otros sitios nos
vamos a tener que poner las pilas.
Por cierto todo este proceso tiene un nombre
propio: Asia.
LA TIERRA DE LA PROSPERIDAD
Casi 9 de cada 10 personas que acceden a la
clase media viven en Asia, el continente del
despegue económico, el continente donde está
el nuevo eje de poder en la tierra
Fijaros, en apenas unos años países como
Filipinas o Tailandia tendrán clases medias
tan grandes como el Reino Unido, Francia o
Italia.
Sí, está claro, seguirán siendo países
mucho más pobres, pero el crecimiento de
su clase media es impresionante.
¿Queréis ver cómo están cambiando las
cosas?
Esto es Jakarta:
¡Y pensad en todo lo que implica para las
empresas!, pero… eso lo vamos a ver un poquito
más tarde.
Ahora bien, de todos los países destaca uno,
China, cuya clase media está literalmente...
explotando.
Fijaros, según las previsiones de la consultora
McKinsey si en 5 años estas personan montasen
la República China de Ciudadanos de Clase
Media sería por si mismo el tercer país
con más habitantes del mundo.
No está mal, ¿Verdad?
Sí queréis ver que significan estos cambios,
atentos a Chongqing, la ciudad más poblada
de China:
Pues bien, como es lógico todas estas personas
que ahora empiezan a tener dinero para gastar,
demandan productos de todo tipo: ropa, electrónica,
coches y, por supuesto, vacaciones.
Sólo en 2016, 120 millones de chinos viajaron
al extranjero y se gastaron más de 100.000
millones de dólares visitando lugares como
Times Square, El Coliseo o las playas de Tailandia.
Ahora ya podéis entender porque los países
de Asia y sobre todo China son tan importantes
para las multinacionales:
“Apple invierte 1.000 millones de dólares
en el “Uber chino”
Fijaros en el siguiente dato, porque si tenéis
un negocio o estáis pensando en montar uno
puede que os interese:
Se estima que tan solo el crecimiento del
consumo de los chinos en los próximos 4 años
va a ser mayor que todo lo que consumen hoy
los alemanes o los británicos.
Vamos, que, si tenéis una empresa, amigos
de VisualPolitik, lo mismo os conviene en
ir dándole una vuelta al mercado asiático,
porque en los próximos años van a aparecer
oportunidades como no habíamos soñado nunca
antes.
Me da que en poco tiempo los cursos de chino
se van a poner bastante de moda.
CONSECUENCIAS DE UNA MAYOR CLASE MEDIA
Pero las consecuencias de todo esto, no solo
significan oportunidades para hacer pasta,
para los negocios.
La consecuencia tal vez más importante de
toda esta expansión de la clase media probablemente
sea que tendremos un mundo más feliz.
Si, haber, me explico.
¿Habéis escuchado eso de que “el dinero
no da la felicidad”?
Bueno, pues según las últimas investigaciones
parece que no es del todo cierto.
En 2010, Angus Deaton y Daniel Kahneman, ambos
Nobel de Economía, presentaron un estudio
que demostraba que, hasta los 75.000 dólares
anuales, la felicidad y los ingresos estaban
muy correlaciones, vamos…
que a más ingresos más felicidad.
Tiene sentido, al fin y al cabo, con más
dinero no tienes que preocuparte de no llegar
a final de mes, de no tener que comer, de
no poder llevar al médico a tu familia, etc,
etc, etc.
Así que, según las investigaciones de estos
académicos, la expansión de la clase media
está dando lugar a un mundo más feliz.
Pero esperad un momento, porque aquí no acaba
todo.
Más clase media supone también personas
más formadas, con más estudios, más investigadores,
más emprendedores en definitiva más ideas,
más innovación y por tanto más progreso.
Pues bien, hoy en China ya hay más estudiantes
universitarios que en los mismísimos Estados
Unidos, así que...
¿Recordáis las empresas que vimos al principio
de este vídeo?
Prepararos, porque dentro de poco habrá muchísimas
más.
Por cierto, esto es Singapur:
Sin embargo, puede que os estéis preguntando…
pero si todo es tan maravilloso como estos
de VisualPolitik me están contando...
¿Cómo puede ser que personajes como Donald
Trump o Marine Le Pen tengan tanto tirón?
Bueno, es verdad que esta gran expansión
de las clases medias se está dando a nivel
global pero no en todos y cada uno de los
sitios del mundo.
Precisamente por eso tenemos que tener claro
que si las economías occidentales no carburan
o tienen problemas, la culpa está en casa
no fuera.
Oportunidades hay, ahora toca adaptarse y
ser capaz de aprovecharlas.
Pero bueno, ya sé lo que muchos estáis pensando:
Esto no puede ser sostenible.
¿No hará todo esto añicos el medio ambiente?
Pues eso no está muy claro.
SOSTENIBILIDAD: INLCUSO AHÍ ES UNA BUENA
NOTICIA
Es verdad, en principio más clase media implica
más consumo de todo y por tanto más presión
sobre los recursos naturales, pero también
tiene otras contrapartidas:
La primera, más clase media supone más gente
en las grandes ciudades, cuyas pautas de consumo
suelen ser en general más sostenibles.
El ejemplo más claro lo podemos ver en el
transporte, mientras que en las ciudades lo
más frecuente es el uso de transportes públicos,
en los sitios más pequeños es todo lo contrario.
Más clase media supone también acelerar
la transición demográfica, es decir, las
mujeres estudian y trabajan, con lo que se
reduce el crecimiento de la población.
Y sobre todo, más clase media, como veíamos
antes supone más ideas y más innovaciones,
entre ellas las que permiten un consumo más
sostenible.
Así que miremos por donde miremos, aunque
aún queda mucho por avanzar y mejorar, creo
que esta vez conviene alegrarse.
Pero bueno, ¿tú qué opinas?
¿Crees que estamos avanzando hacia un mundo
mejor?
¿Piensas que Asia puede ser una tierra de
oportunidades para hacer negocios?
Déjanos tu opinión en los comentarios, y
si te ha gustado este vídeo no dudes en darle
a Like y suscribirte al canal si aún no lo
has hecho.
Por cierto, si quieres ver cómo la pobreza
está retrocediendo en todo el mundo, incluido
en África no te pierdas este vídeo en que
te lo cuento con todo detalle.
Un saludo y hasta el próximo domingo en La
Vanguardia